all right you guys well it's always five
o'clock somewhere and apparently happy
hour starts a bit early for some of us
working from home during the pandemic
one poll surveyed 2
000 americans who are working from home
found about
half 46 percent have clocked out early
to pour themselves a drink at least once
during quarantine
another 45 percent admitted to drinking
during
the work day and 53 say they are
drinking alcohol just
in general more often during lockdown
you know when you're on the zoom
and the person's camera goes black and
you're like what are they doing
yes that's what's going on that's apple
cider
cheers you guys sure it is uh uh
it's cranberry cranberry juice okay the
healthy juice
yeah because uh alex and sherry you guys
know that working in the morning
that's a little tough to do you know you
could do a mimosa
okay or we'll do cranberry juice there
you go hey have a great weekend you guys
enjoy sharing cheers you guys bye bye
happy friday
you got it salute